hey little guys my name is the churner
and welcome back to my opengl series
mixing it up a little bit with the set I
mean last one you you guys were
certainly noticing that that I was just
I waved my hands around a lot I was
coming pretty close to hitting that
cactus occasionally and that was just I
don't want to lose a hand
so we're basically mixing it up with
basically Cheney I thought I make a
subtle kind of change just to get rid of
that whole risk of losing a hand I
didn't want to overreact or anything
like that so I changed the set slightly
kind of got rid of cactus it's still in
this room but it's all the way over
there anyway hope you guys like this new
kind of format it's gonna be a lot more
casual because I am not a big fan of
being professional quite do it to be
quite frank with you guys and hopefully
this is just gonna be gonna be a little
bit a little bit a little bit easier for
you guys to watch and listen to as well
without kind of me going through
everything like a robot and just quickly
kind of end up having to spend like an
hour or two editing every single video
so anyway welcome back to my opengl
series last time we talked about shader
stuff and in fact the last two episodes
we've been kind of talking about shader
stuff specifically we talked about what
shadows were and we actually had a go at
writing a very simple vertex and
fragment shader the basically just made
our triangle read if you guys haven't
seen that episode yeah definitely click
up there because you need to watch that
in order to get this video because what
this video is going to is going to be
about is just basically continuing on
with that and more specifically I'm
going to show you how I like to deal
with traitors because kind of what we've
been doing right now with the code is
basically I mean if we look at the code
that we had last time we have this
function where we compile a shader and
then we kind of created and all of that
but we still have to basically take it
and well the biggest problem here right
now for us is that we still need to take
it in kind of as strings that's a bit of
an issue because well first of all
looking at these strings you can see we
have to add new line characters and
quotes everywhere it's just not very
like comfortable for us to write shaders
at this point in it it's pretty easy to
just miss a new line or something like
that and end up with some kind of bug
and I don't want to really do that so
we're going to fix that up so that we
can actually take our shaders in from a
file and specifically what I see a lot
of people doing which is
completely reasonable because OpenGL
does kind of enforce it to a degree is
that what people will actually do is
create two different files one for the
vertex shader and one for the fragment
shader I'm really not a fan of that to
be honest I mean having two different
files of Y I mean in some cases it can
be useful to divide shaders up for
example you might have a vertex shader
which just takes in like a certain
amount of parameters set amount of
inputs and just outputs a position and
that's it'll provide some kind of data
to the fragment shader and it might be a
really simple vertex shader which you
could pair up with three different
fragment shaders for example and in that
case you might argue well okay you know
I'm loading this file I don't want to
necessarily tie the two shaders together
like the vertex and the fragment shader
together don't necessarily want to do
that's one argument but we've got us
like we'll deal with that as well in a
minute here but the big thing is that I
don't like having to it like why I have
to I have two different files right
there's no actual reason for that it's
actually a little bit annoying you have
to make two different files you have to
read in two different files when you're
editing them you have to like switch
between the two I have them open side by
side it's just not very comfortable and
I'm all about comfort like clearly I'm
sitting on a couch here instead of a
chair and a table so what I like to do
is combine the two shaders into one file
right just have one file with a vertex
and a fragment shader and of course in
the future if you want to use one vertex
shader with a bunch of fragment shaders
you can still do that you can still
because obviously when we give the
shaders to opengl at the end they still
need to have that clear division right
we can't just simply give opengl one
like one string of source code and then
it can deal with it it still needs to
kind of know it still needs to kind of
have that distinction between this is my
vertex shader source code and this is my
fragment shader source code and we're
still gonna provide it with that it's
just on outside basically as the users
the programmers the developer writing
this kind of code we're going to write
it all in one file and I'll show you how
we divide it into two shaders in a
minute this is very much like DirectX
you might you might actually kind of
throughout this series you'll probably
see me reference direct3d 11
specifically quite a lot with how I
actually organize my OpenGL code because
when you deal with
you'll be using multiple api's multiple
graphics API is most likely give us a
serious engine and you kind of will
probably if your engine supports
direct3d or even if it doesn't you'll
probably find yourself making OpenGL
behave more like DirectX because DirectX
is just a better API anyway let's get
into some code and I'll show you how all
this is going to work so the first thing
we're actually going to do is just
create a file which contains these two
shaders so that we know how we're
actually going to deal with them so over
here in my client source directory I'm
actually going to right click on OpenGL
hit add and then new folder we're gonna
call this rest which stands for
resources and then under that res folder
I'm actually going to create another
folder called shaders and this is
specifically going to be for shaders
well we will have other resources like
textures and stuff like that in the
future so I just want to keep all of
this really nice and tidy we'll
right-click on shaders hit add new item
and then here I'm just going to add a
file now
doesn't matter what you click here
because we're kind of gonna change the
extension anyway we're just going to
call this shader dot shader or
specifically we might rename this to
something like well I don't know it just
makes a it makes a triangle red we're
just gonna call it basic shader because
this is just going to be like our basic
shader that we deal with I'm gonna hit
add and now we have a shader you can see
that it's not showing up as like the C++
icon which is very important we don't
want to accidentally compile this as C++
code because of course here won't
compile let's go back to application or
cpp I'm going to copy this entire kind
of block of code and I want to paste it
into this file now we need to clean this
up a little bit specifically I'm going
to get rid of this string of course from
both of these here and then to actually
clean this up we could go through this
kind of line by line it's gonna be a bit
hard so I'll show you guys a bit of a
trick if you hit ctrl H that will bring
up the Find and Replace dialog which you
can see over here we're going to grab
quotes and replace them with nothing if
you hit alt a or I think there's a
replace all button here okay we'll get
rid of all that and then finally want to
get rid of through new lines as well so
I'll also replace backslash and with
nothing okay done and there we go you
can see how much easier that was and
kind of just going through this code and
cleaning everything up manually okay
fantastic we've got this kind of hard to
tell the distinction there between a
vertex and a fragment shader
so what I like to do you just come up
here
top and I'm gonna hit hash shader and
then vertex okay and then I'm going to
copy that and just above the fragment
shader call this fragment so when we
have all of our different shaders we
might have other shader types like
tessellation shaders or something like
that geometry shaders that kind of stuff
we can also probably add a section for
that but for now you can see that I've
clearly kind of divided this into my
fragment shader and my vertex shader
don't worry too much about the syntax
highlighting here because we are we have
actually specify the dull shader
exception Visual Studio is probably go
to try and highlight this as if it was a
cello sounds like a direct s kind of
shader
but anyway that's they're still kind of
sort of helpful for us because it
highlights some things like the numbers
and it kind of makes that easier to see
but you can see how this is kind of my
strategy for laying out chatters it's
very easy you can see what's going on
all at once you don't need to flip
between two different files and it's
just yeah it's just really nice and easy
and and clean and organized so let's go
back to our application I'm gonna get
rid of this entire block here now now to
kind of understand what's going on here
we have our create shader function which
takes in the two strings of source code
we still need to provide it with two
different strengths of source code so
now really our plan is just to take this
file and divide it up into two blocks of
strings right into two strings our
fragment shader source code and our
vertex shader source code let's go back
to application and do that I'm gonna
scroll up here our up here to the very
top more to try this function at the top
why not static will make it void for now
and we'll call this pause shader and
then I'm going to just make this take in
a Const sed string and this will be a
our file might call this file path and
the way that we're actually gonna read
this in is of course first of all we
need to open a file and I'm going to do
this in a bit of like a C++ modern c++
way not necessarily the way that I would
personally read files in a game engine
because C++ tends to be a little bit
slower than the C kind of file API but
because this series is obviously just
about OpenGL
I want to kind of write car that's a lot
easier to read and a lot safer and all
that so I'm just going to basically
include something called F stream which
says the file stream and then over here
I'm going to write s/pdif stream we'll
just call it stream
input file stream and then I'll kind of
give it that file path that's the the
actual file that we're trying to open
yet that already opens the file so now
what we need to do is actually go
through that file line-by-line
and just check to see hey are we
specifying a certain shade of time
because we've kind of added our own
syntax right we've got this hash shader
vertex thing you know which basically
says hey this is a new shader section
and this is the type of the shader that
it is so we need to kind of read in that
and we're going to go through the file
line-by-line and the way we'll do that
is we'll actually do while stream yeah
we'll use a function called get lines so
well get line stream and then we'll make
a string here called line which will
contain our actual line while that
doesn't equal zero basically now get
loan is a function that actually is
inside the string header so we need to
include string so while get line is
still kind of valid which means there
are still more lines for us to read
inside the file we're going to just
basically check to see line or find if
that actual line contains our shader on
a custom syntax token here and if that
doesn't equal STD string and pause which
is basically an invalid string position
because fine will return us the actual
string position you can see it returns a
size T it doesn't return a boolean or
anything like that with whether or not
it actually found our string it actually
just returns us the position of it so if
it's end positive means it doesn't it
hasn't found it so if it has found
shader on that line we need to basically
find which type of shader it is and
again I'm just gonna use line defines if
it if it's gonna be vertex if it finds
vertex then we're going to basically
have to set the kind of mode to vertex
which we'll do in a minute and otherwise
though if it finds fragments so if that
doesn't equal STD string and pause then
we're going to set them are true
fragments okay so that's kind of how
this is gonna work we're just going to
go through it line by line and we're
going to keep adding vertex well if this
if the type is set to vertex we're going
to keep adding these lines basically to
our vertex shader string if it's
fragment were going to add them to the
fragment shader string pretty simple so
now we actually need to add the strings
that we're reading out these lines that
we're
into some kind of buffer where we can
just pile on line by line what the
vertex chatter the fragment shader is so
to do that I'm going to use something
called string stream so we'll have to
include that and that'll be on the
include s stream if we scroll down here
I'm just going to make two different
string streams so we'll call this s s
and I'm actually just gonna use a kind
of stack allocated or right here to have
two of them one of them is going to be
for the vertex chatter of course one of
them is going to be for the fragment
shader and the idea is we we need to
have some kind of mode as well so are we
currently reading in a vertex shader or
a fragment shader but to do that I'm
just gonna create an enum class here
called shader type and then we're gonna
have nine which is negative one then
we're going to have a vertex of course
which is zero and fragment which is one
I'm being very explicit with these
numbers and I'll tell you why in a
minute we're also going to store the
current shader type that we're reading
in so we'll set this equal to none by
default okay cool
so if we find vertex if we find shader
vertex on a line we need to set the mode
or the type to actually be shared a type
of vertex and then of course for
fragment we can set it equal to fragment
I'm kind of setting this up loosely I
could be a little bit cleaner with my
code and actually have some more
functions and stuff like that to work
out what the type is from string but
again it's stoical this is a really
simple function so once i've done that
if if i kind of if we see hash shader on
a line we know that when you just had a
type otherwise if it's any other kind of
line of code then we actually need to
add it to either the vertex or the
fragment shader source code and the way
we do that is to this string stream let
me just arrow to this extra space to
this string stream I'm going to
basically push the line into a non
internal which one to push too and
that's why we've got the trader type so
I'm going to grab the type and just cast
it to an end and use it as an index into
this array we know that the array
contains two elements and we know
they're basically the first element in
that array is going to be vertex and the
second one is going to be fragment so
I'm kind of using arrays here in a
little bit of a clever way to actually
you know automate this little bit more
so that I don't have to have a branch
where I basically say if the type is you
know vertex add it to the vertex trick
stream if the type is fragment add it to
the fragment string stream I can kind of
just use the type as an index into the
array which is just gonna be a little
bit better basically so over here I'm
going to basically add lime into that
strength stream followed by a new line
character just like that and that's
pretty much it I mean if you look at
this code this should divide our shadow
into two different types and add them to
the appropriate string string so finally
at the end here I need to actually
return my code now we have a little bit
of an issue because we are trying to
return two strings and of course you can
only return one kind of you can return
one variable in C++ so how do we return
two variables now we could use something
called a tuple or a pair I actually have
a lot of feelings about that actually I
might make a simple splice video this
week maybe that actually deals with with
this kind of multiple return type thing
specifically I think I will actually
that's probably a good idea I don't like
using that stuff and I'll explain why in
the syphillis video I don't want to bore
you guys here but what I would do if I
need to can return multiple types here
is I would actually make a struct called
shader
I don't know shader sources or something
like that we might actually just call
this shader program sauce and this is
actually going to contain our will call
this vertex sauce I kind of like to
capitalize a bit I'm kind of treating
this almost like a c-sharp property
that's why I'm capitalizing this because
there are just public fields so we're
taking vertex sauce and fragment sauce
okay cool very basic struct and I'm
going to just return that struct and
then at the end here of my function was
I have the - once I've built up and I've
read all the source code from that file
I'm just going to return basically a
struct that this structure I so I'm
gonna set the vertex source to be SS 0
dot s TR and then SS 1 STR ok which
gives us the string back from the string
stream and that's all we need to do
right now so this code should set us up
with the actual share the source code
for both the vertex and the fragment
shader awesome so now let's scroll down
and actually test this out so the first
thing I'll do is I'll kind of
we might just get rid of our shader for
now just by commenting it out I just
really want to see if my function works
first to be honest so we'll go shader
program sauce sauce or something like
that equals positive and then we'll take
in our file path which is just going to
be res slash shaders slash basic shader
which is our file so res slash shaders
slash basic shader now this is kind of
the first instance of us actually
reading a file in C++ in the series on
my channel so basically what you need to
know about this is that if you specify a
relative path like that so not something
that is an absolute path you know like C
uses whatever starting from the C Drive
was whatever since we're specifying a
relative path relative paths are always
from the working directory now if you
run the executable outside a bit of
studio the default working directory is
just going to be the directory that
contains that executable so everything
will be relative to that but if we're
running this through the visual studio
debugger the working directory is
actually set by our Bureau studio
debugging kind of properties so if we
right click on open on the open shell
project hit properties you can see over
here we have a tab called debugging
right and under here we have a working
directory you can see here that is set
by default to our project directory so
we know that this file is relative to
the project directory that is the
directory that actually contains our
project file which in this case is this
directory which is has our VCS proj so
you can see it should be relative to
this so res slash adders slash basic dog
shader and that's exactly what I've
written over here now that we've got
this let's actually just see our source
vertex source and also I'll do the same
for fragment source now to divide this
in some way just to make it extra clear
I'm also going to copy this kind of
twice here and write you know vertex
like that and fragment so that we can
really see the two different shadow
types we have and I'm just gonna hit f5
ok I got one more syntax error here when
we do jail to lay shattered by the way
this code was wrong from the last
episode I added a little thing kind of
just in Premiere Pro much like in my
video editing software I just had a
little kind of nard being like this is
what it should be it should not be GL
delete shad I don't know why I wrote
that it should be jailed delete pro
Brown okay because shader is actually
just one shader type our program is to
actually go to delay our programs that's
what it should be let's comment that out
for now though because we did kind of
comment that shadow code
let's hit f5 to run this program
hopefully we can see our pausing working
correctly so if I go to my console you
should see that we have vertex and then
do actuator and fragment and then the
fragment shader so it looks pretty good
to me they look like they're out correct
shader there's nothing cracks or
anything like that looks pretty perfect
to me let's go ahead and actually pipe
that into our source code or
specifically to our shared a compilation
function so I'll bring this back and
I'll bring back my GL delete program as
well and then instead of kind of
providing vertex shader and fragment
shader now we've got this we can just
provide source dot the vertex source and
source dot fragment sauce just like that
let's hit f5 and you can see that we get
a red triangle if I go back to my basic
shader file let's go ahead and change it
let's make it I don't know let's just
make it a nice little blue so I'll make
a 0.2 0.3 0.8 and then hit at 5 as you
can see we get a nice blue triangle
awesome so I hope you guys enjoyed this
video we basically just took what we had
with shaders made it a little bit better
combine it all into one file and now we
can crash edits from files which is
pretty cool and gonna be way more easier
it's gonna be way easier for us to
actually do that as we progress on with
this series now in the future we will
probably abstract all this into a class
as the code based kind of keeps drawing
found we're not gonna worry about it
we're just gonna move on we've covered
vertex buffers and shaders the next step
that I really want to cover is going to
be about index buffers okay because we
need a way to actually render our
triangle using something called an index
buffer and we'll talk about why we want
one of those what that actually is and
all that in the next video because it's
probably not that apparent the need for
it probably isn't that apparent with a
triangle but as we kind of get more
complex valve geometry I mean even if we
try and render a square which is pretty
complex right it's gonna benefit it's
gonna basically be a huge benefit for us
to use something called an index buffer
anyway I hope you guys enjoy this video
if you did you can hit the like button
you can help support this series by
going over to patreon
for such the churner there are some
pretty cool rewards I mean I'm not gonna
lie there's I would never lie to you
guys right first of all this series
would be absolutely nothing without my
patreon supporters there's no way that I
would be sitting here on a couch
spending this much time making videos
for you guys unless I was getting the
support so this is thank you so much for
letting me do this first of all but
second of all you'll get videos early
you'll get access to all the source code
kind of episode by episode for this
series and really for all of my series
and there's this really cool thing where
basically if you're a top-tier kind of
supporter this is hangout that we do
once a month we're basically all the
supporters get into one like video chat
thing on discord and we just talk about
we just hang out for an hour basically
just talk about whatever it's a really
good time so definitely sign up for that
if you're interested in help support
series this port is also a really good
place to talk about this stuff rather
than just leaving a comment below which
you could do as well of course I try and
respond to all my comments you can also
head on over to discord com4 sorry the
cherubic home slash discord where
there's basically just a community of
people like a instant messaging kind of
format thing with multiple channels
where you can talk about this triangle
the opengl seriously plus whatever it is
that you want to talk about a lot of
people there as well that can help you
out with all your problems and of course
don't forget to follow me on Twitter and
on Instagram the conference at the
channel as well just plugging absolutely
everything also you can buy the merch at
this I'm kidding I don't have that link
yet but I'll get back to you with that
shortly next time index buffers
Cherno out goodbye
[Music]